The number one thing in a business owner
is a hungry business owner, right?
Because they, you're not gonna find,
you can't, as much as I would love
to have every business owner be good at sales,
most of them suck.
Like they're like old plumber,
let's say it's in the plumbing industry for septic, right?
Cause we do septic.
They're probably an old plumber
that decided to open their own company.
They're not trained in sales, not always.
If you find one that are good at plumbing
and business people, those ones are really good.
Typically you don't find that.
So you have to remember, it's kind of like,
like I guess, so Aaron, Aaron is currently single,
just FYI for any of the ladies out there.
At some point, Aaron's gonna start fricking working
the field, Aaron's gonna start hunting, you know?
He's gonna start fricking prowling around
and he's gonna wanna have a list of things,
even if it's in his head of things that he's looking for.
And as much as he'd like to have every single
one of those things, which he could,
he may be looking for a long time.
And so you kind of have to have this list
within your head of like, what do you want
that business owner, it's your partner.
What are the things ideally you'd want
that business owner to have?
And then in what order are they most important?
And to me, the most important thing is a hunger for leads.
Because if they're hungry for leads,
then they're gonna do their very, very best.
And they may not be perfect on the phone.
They may sound really gravely and scary
and they might have not great customer service,
but at least they're hungry, they're following up,
they want that business.
On the other hand, they can be the best talker
in the world, they can be the best whatever communicator.
But if they're not hungry for the leads,
they're not, like Francesca said,
they're not gonna call them.
They're not gonna address them.
They're not gonna, you're gonna really,
really get frustrated.
So to me, the number one thing I look for
is a hungry business owner.
And how do we know that guys?
Aaron, how do we know someone's hungry typically?
When they actually are responsive?
They're responsive, but also going back
to building the list is-
Oh, they're already paying for it, yeah.
They're already paying for it.
Because if they're already paying,
they're either A, hungry for more leads,
or B, they're allergic to money, right?
And the chance of it being B is low, right?
So, great question.